[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
en france un ehpad n'est contrôlé que
tous les 20 à 30 ans
c'est en partant de ce constat que la
commission des affaires sociales s'est
saisie de cette problématique
essentielle poursuivant ainsi ses
réflexions sur l'organisation du secteur
du grand âge entamée depuis plusieurs
années
le 13 juillet les sénateurs catherine de
roche bernard bonne et michel meunier
ont ainsi rendu les conclusions de ses
travaux consacrés à cette question du
contrôle des ehpad et plus largement à
l'exercice du pilotage stratégique du
secteur par l'état et les autorités de
tarification
les sénateurs ont constaté des lacunes
dans le contrôle des établissements
imputable à la réglementation mais aussi
aux moyens insuffisants qui sont
consacrés
récemment le gouvernement a réagi en
lançant une campagne d'inspection pour
que les 7500 ehpad de france soient
contrôlés d'ici deux ans avec des
renforts en personnel accordée aux ars
le rapport du sénat veut aller plus loin
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales et celle des finances devraient
être chargés de contrôler tous les
groupes intervenant dans le secteur en
commençant par les groupes privés
commerciaux
quant à la campagne de contrôle annoncée
par le gouvernement
elle devrait être étendue aux sièges des
groupes privés lucratifs
de plus une actualisation du système de
sanction inadaptée paraît nécessaire
parallèlement le déploiement d'un
pilotage par la qualité est jugée
indispensable à une meilleure prise en
charge des résidents
dans cette optique les sénateurs
recommandent la généralisation de la
démarche qualité en établissement
encadrés par des indicateurs public et
le regard d'une tierce partie
par exemple pour lutter contre la
maltraitance en ehpad la mission
préconise notamment une obligation de
réponse aux signalements adressés par
les familles aux autorités tarifie
catrice et de contrôle
du fait des perspectives démographiques
il faudrait ouvrir 50 6000 places en
ehpad d'ici 2030
la commission préconise d'engager des
mutations profondes pour le secteur
les sénateurs souhaitent d'abord une
meilleure coordination du contrôle des
ehpad qui doit se faire à l'échelle de
chaque département
en outre les sénateurs encouragés à
investir dans la modernisation du bâti
des ehpad et de revoir les dispositifs
fiscaux sur l'investissement privé
de plus l'offre d'ehpad à but lucratif
qui dépasse 50 % des lits dans certains
départements ne devrait pas excéder un
certain pourcentage
enfin au delà d'une réforme du contrôle
et de la gouvernance des ehpad et alors
que la population de personnes âgées
dépendantes pourraient atteindre quatre
millions en 2050 la commission des
affaires sociales juge indispensable
d'examiner une loi consacré au grand âge
et à l'autonomie
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]